welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and shang chi in the legend of the
10 rings introduces a new avenger to the
mcu deeply rooted in mystic mythology
unafraid to pose cryptic questions about
the monsters in the shadows of our
dimension and the wonderful weirdos wong
has been hanging out with i'm gonna
break down this film scene by scene for
all the deeper layers of meaning and the
marvel easter eggs that you might have
missed the film opens on the black flag
of the ten rings the army of win woo
played by the great tony lang who
possesses the ten rings now the tin
rings organization has appeared in the
mcu since the beginning the terrorist
network who kidnapped tony stark and the
first iron man the operative who aided
ivan vanko and iron man 2 the weapons
buyer and ant-man and of course
iconography appropriated in iron man 3
by aldrich killian and the false
mandarin the paid actor trevor slattery
who actually returns in this film after
being extracted from seagate prison by
forces of the true mandarin in the 2014
short film all hail the king now
viewable on disney plus but here on this
flag the 10 rings logo has had its
central weapons replaced with the hook
swords used by wynwoo's warriors and
within each of these rings is a
character from an ancient chinese
calligraphy known as seal script going
from the top it means power or authority
clockwise to the right means physical
strength the third means strong or
robust yeah a lot of these translate to
some version of strength or power kind
of like the ten rings what's up the
fourth means extraordinary magnificent
or great the fifth means hero heroic or
outstanding person the sixth means power
influence it's also associated with the
male genitals the seventh means large
extensive great in the literal sense the
eighth means powerful or grand and also
refers to things that are male the ninth
means strong or powerful and the tenth
means pomp or power now wenwu himself is
based on the iron man villain of the
mandarin for the marvel comics later
renamed zhang zhu but he's also kind of
based on shang chi's traditional father
a character known as fu manchu yes
another bit of very problematic history
that marvel has retconned over the years
now in the comics the ten rings are an
ancient alien mcluhan technology each
containing the spirit of a cosmic
warrior giving each ring a different
ability but here the film reconceives
them as equally powered wrist bracelets
evoking the iron strength bracelets of
chinese martial arts like hungar the
mandarin in the comics found the mcluhan
rings in the crashed alien spacecraft of
axon carr and later on in this film it
is said that win woo might have found
them in a crater or a tomb but it's
never confirmed though it looks like the
post-credits scene starts to go more
into their origin now in the mcu past
ten rings members razza and jackson
norris bragged about the tin rings
history of conquest in the asian
continent the bow and arrow once was the
pinnacle of weapons technology it
allowed the great genghis khan to rule
from the pacific
to the ukraine he was a warrior king
inspired generations of men through the
middle ages and now we actually get to
see that history as when wu whips his
ten rings into a shield that deflects
all enemy arrows the previous pinnacle
of technology now being supplanted by
his and i love this shot where he
extends his rings hovering from his fist
like a collapsible baton just like we
saw norris use in all hail the king now
the film returns to these extensive
flashbacks throughout the narrative so
for now just to stick with the
chronology when wu travels through a
bamboo forest and discovers a clearing
guarded by zhang li falachen's character
who duels him in this beautiful
acrobatic ballet with movements that are
actually based on tai chi contrastingly
the combat style of win woo in the style
that he trains his son and all of his
warriors is based on wing chun a
traditional southern chinese kung fu but
zhang li's style reigns supreme as she
knocks him off balance her fighting
style incorporates air bending something
the people of tallow seem to be skilled
at and it gives them a special
connection to the earth that win woo's
mastery over tech that is actually alien
from another world can't really compete
with she's literally on her home turf
it's a lovely story that we get to see
and it's a genre referred to as wushia
you may have also seen it in titles like
crouching tiger hidden dragon it refers
to mythological romances set amidst
picturesque natural landscapes the
cinematographer of this film was bill
pope who actually shot the matrix and
you can see the parallels and the warm
color tones and the wire work and the
way zhang li dodges the rings almost as
if in bullet time now the rings glow
blue whenever they're used by win woo
contrasting the golden colors associated
with shanxi and his mother and her
people blue is a colder color tone
associated with death since that really
is how win woo uses these rings whereas
gold is associated with sunlight in life
wenwu gives himself a chance at life by
locking his rings away giving up
immortality falling in love with zhang
li and having two children chongqi and
xi ling their mother gives them both
these green pendant necklaces but the
fun comes to an end when when wu's
former enemies find him the iron gang
and they attack while he's away killing
shang lee now it is interesting that
they are called the iron gang and iron
man is a long time enemy to the mandarin
in the comics but that might just be a
parallel i'm seeing so in his grief
winwoo returns to his rings gets his
revenge and brutally trains his son into
a killing machine to follow in his
footsteps he does this with the help of
his lieutenant a death dealer based on
the killer death dealer lee shin ling in
the comics when wu ordered strong chi to
kill the head of the iron gang and
shanghai never returns home afterward
leaving his sister behind bringing us to
the modern day in san francisco chongqi
going by the name sean played by simulu
lives in a garage and there's a poster
on his wall for the movie kung fu hustle
a martial arts action comedy a must-see
which also features the use of iron
strength bracelets he and his friend
katie played by aquafina work as valets
at the fairmont hotel in a fun fake out
since if you think about it several
other marvel heroes have been introduced
as the owners of nice sports cars as
opposed to the people who park them
chongxie eats breakfast with katie's
family but on the way in outside the
building there's a poster reading post
blip anxiety you are not alone national
blip support hotline i guess kind of
like a post-in-game version of what
steve rogers had in end game but now
this for people going through the kind
of drama monaco rambo went through at
the hospital or that poor midtown high
tuba player who got tackled
there's also a poster for something
called blip sync which according to
interviews with the screenwriters is a
dating app for those who were blipped
good luck getting them to be honest
about their ages he mistakenly sits in
the seat of katie's grandmother's late
husband and katie and her mother debate
the importance of superstitiously
clinging to the memory of dead loved
ones which is her first hit at this
movie's deeper theme of ancestral grief
chungchi as a character wants to escape
the bloodshed of his ancestry while his
father lets his grief drive him mad and
threatened to spread literal
soullessness across the world so shanghi
must learn to channel his pain from his
father into something different
something positive which is an idea
director daniel destin credence said was
key to his own journey of self-discovery
while crafting this film these rings
symbolize that ancestral weight dragging
when woo down but when transferred to
his son they change color and become a
force for good katie tells shongxi about
her art of confusion defense tactic
which is randomly singing the eagles
hotel california ironically katie and
shangchi work at a hotel in california
where they may feel like they in the
words of the song can check out any time
they like but they can never leave
now they sing aladdin's a whole new
world in karaoke reflecting their
escapist fantasies of trying to find a
whole new world but then in the
post-credits scene they hilariously come
back to hotel california with wong
because as he said there's no turning
back they're now trapped in this
avengers crisis world and they can never
leave haiti and shanghai get jumped on a
bus with amazing stunt work that keeps
your eye on the real object of this
fight not shanghi himself but his
necklace meanwhile in the early rounds
of the fight you'll notice razor frisk
glowers at them from the back of the bus
with fighter flory and montyanu playing
the assassin from the comics watching
this all go down is comedian zack cherry
as cleve yo what up y'all it's your boy
cliff coming at you live on the bus i
actually did take a little bit of
martial arts as a youth so i'm gonna try
and grade this fight as we're going this
same guy previously appeared in
spider-man homecoming he told spider-man
to do a flip okay spider-man
don't flip
yeah and then after that movie came out
zak cherry went on stephen colbert
pushing a campaign for do a flip guy to
get his own mcu spin-off so it's awesome
to see him come back here now look
closely at the comments on clev's live
stream they include at capiopia saying
these dudes are regretting their life
decisions then that anti-darkness saying
unreal with a purple background this
could be auntie agnes aka agatha
harkness often clad in purple not really
sure what her reality is because at this
point over in west view she's stuck in a
trance after wanda maximoff left her
there in the one division final episode
and then there's climbing guy 3000 who
says i literally can't even this could
be an alias of peter parker who loves
climbing and he could be shouting out
the guy who loved us three thousand
you'll also notice how several of the
commenters praised seong chi's fighting
skills calling him bus boy which is a
bit of viral fame similar to how peter
parker initially got the attention of
the whole world and of tony stark in
online videos just like this and he was
a boy literally also saving the city bus
and after he takes down a few of them
the extra extra award goes to jean
jacket here who crosses her arms until
the guy falls and her eyes bulge out at
chiang chi now contrasting the more
stylized fight choreography of his
elders chongchi's combat is more
practical and slapstick he uses his
jacket he springs off the elasticity of
the bus joint bellows all parts of his
environment to subdue his foes this
style was made famous by jackie chan
films all coming from this movie's stunt
coordinator the late brad allen who was
a member of the jackie chan stunt team
receives a lovely tribute in this
movie's credits and you can see more of
this intricate stunt work later in the
scaffolding fight chongqi uses the
planks balanced on the bamboo to both
swing himself down to the lower level
while seesawing it to knock someone in
the head and then later knocks down an
enemy to turn that person into a bridge
to run across and then knock them down
it's all like a big elaborate game of
mousetrap it's super fun to watch but
back to the bus fight it all goes down
in three acts the second act begins as
the bus enters the tunnel and notice the
camera stays on chiang chi from the
exterior of the bus as he works his way
down it from right to left he throws
dudes out the window just kind of mows
them down paralleling the amazing
lateral camera movement in the iconic
hallway fight in the 2003 movie old boy
but the third act of this battle creates
this hilarious crisis of katie having to
take the wheel now as razorfist slices
the bellows look carefully because at
first you can see the necklace around
shang chi's neck but then he turns his
back to us and razor fist starts moving
his other hand around and then when
shengshi kicks razor fist into the back
half as it tears off around the turn and
he leaps at us into the front half of
the bus you can see chung chi's neck is
bare and his necklace is now gone and
that must have been the moment razorfist
snatched it but shanxi doesn't realize
it until later now at dinner their
friend references the blip when she says
they live in a world where anyone can
disappear at any moment so again yes
this is set after endgame and notice how
xiangxi wears a silmar high school shirt
that on the back says class of 2017. so
if 10 years have now passed since
xiangxi ran away when he was 14 years
old if he graduated in the year 2017
that would set this movie in july 2024
by the jazz music festival ads on the
bus studying this at almost exactly the
same time as spider-man apart from home
when he was in europe and also allowing
us to conclude that chongqi to be this
old must have survived the snap and must
have had to age during those five years
now to be honest it's easier to catch
these details after you've had a good
night of sleep but no matter how hard i
try it's just hard to get my bedroom
completely dark at night like i got
chargers i got alarms power strips
everywhere it's a constellation of tiny
electric stars brightening up my room
and just making it harder to fall asleep
but that's where the blue blocks remedy
sleep mask comes in handy and thanks to
blue blocks for sponsoring this video we
already know blue blocks from their blue
light blocking glasses but their sleep
mask goes farther and blocks out 100 of
light so that you can sleep better it
has adjustable eye cups and an
adjustable strap to get everyone the
perfect fit and it works for people who
sleep on their belly on their side and
on their back check it out you can fully
open your eyes while wearing it yeah my
eyes are open right now does that creep
you out it is great for improving sleep
and meditation napping and of course
it's great for flying so go to
blueblocks.com new rockstar so just
click the link below and you will get 20
off your remedy sleep mask today my code
is automatically applied for that 20 off
so all you need to do is click the link
below and enjoy free shipping on orders
over 115 dollars to get the best sleep
possible right now get yourself a blue
blocks remedy sleep mask just go to
b-l-u-b-l-o-x dot com new rockstars or
click the link below to get 20 off your
order code automatically applied at
checkout chung chi follows a postcard
leading them to macau along with katie
to this cage fighting club owned by his
sister jai ling but operated by ronnie
chang as john john this club is called
the golden daggers club now the golden
dagger was a name from early shang chi
comics master of kung fu number 44 and
it was the name of one of boo manchu's
subsidiary groups now in the various
low-level fights in the rooms of the
background is a sumo wrestler there's
also a female warrior we know stunt
actress jay ju returns in this movie
after she played a black widow agent in
the movie black widow and in the credits
she is credited as widow meaning she is
the same character from black widow
which might be why she now wears black
with a red belt and she must be one of
those freed black widows from the red
room and now she's fighting him a cow
give her a spin-off there's also a
fighter with flesh glowing red orange
apparently a recipient of ames extremist
treatment from iron man 3 suggesting
that some of aldrich killian's test
subjects might have gotten away from
that battle and one of them now has his
life fighting in cage matches on the
other side of the world but the marquee
batch of course is wong dr strange's
fellow sorcerer fighting abomination now
remember abomination was emil blonsky
tim roth who fought the edward norton
version of hulk and harlem in the 2008
film and we believe has been imprisoned
ever since it is amazing to see him
return in the mcu here this version of
him looks different with a greener color
and head bins he also wears pants
similar to his appearance from the
comics but this change was never
explained i presume the way hulk's
redesign between the 2008 film and the
avengers wasn't really explained either
but wong does call him emile in this
movie so it is the same character after
abomination actually hits wong wong gets
him back by opening the portal to make
abomination knock himself out similar to
how wong used clever portal tricks to
beat big boy call ob city in an infinity
war later the two appear to retreat to
what looks like a facility that looks
like it has a high-tech containment cell
in there maybe where blonsky is being
forced to stay when he's not sparring in
macau with wong this facility could be
the raft prison or some other facility
overseen by thaddeus ross because maybe
blonsky is being allowed to train as
part of ross and valve's upcoming
thunderbolts initiative and maybe they
only trusted wong this sorcerer to be
his chaperone meanwhile chongqi fights
his sister behind him is a flag that
looks like the flag of magipore the
fictional southeast asian country that
appeared in the falcon winter soldier
the postcard we found out was sent not
by xiling but by their father a trick to
trap both of them in the same place at
the same time chung chi fights the tin
rings warriors on the scaffolding and
fights death dealer until his father
appears and lays a gentle but terrifying
ring-equipped wrist on his shoulder so
they all return to the ten rings
compound where when wu reconciles the
mcu's past depictions of the mandarin
legend with his truth laughing how
aldrich killian invented the mandarin
boogeyman identity naming it after a
chicken dish and we actually see on his
video screens footage of tony stark's
captivity by the tin rings in the first
iron man film when wu plugs shang chi
and xi ling's necklace pendants into the
eyes of the wooden dragon carving in his
shrine causing water to flow out and
mystically bend revealing the path in
the bamboo forest maze that will lead to
tah bo zhang lee's hidden kingdom that
he was never allowed to enter and where
he now believes her soul to be trapped
in a cave voices calling out to him now
in the marvel comics talo is one of the
god realms a small pocket dimension
adjacent to earth the great canopy of
heaven home to celestial dragons and a
phoenix like fang huang the wooden
quillin beasts and the canine like
heitei and the race known as the jian
i'm sorry if i mispronounced any of that
and surviving in this compound's dungeon
is trevor slattery ben kingsley serving
as the jester he recaps what he went
through in iron man 3 and in the all
hail the king short and when they
stumble upon him here he was quoting the
knock knock knock monologue from
shakespeare's macbeth the drunken porter
from act 2 scene 3 and in that scene the
porter imagines himself as the man
answering the gate of hell reinforcing
one of the themes of that play that the
castle setting is really a form of hell
for the characters and for trevor
slattery this is a speech that amused
win woo enough into keeping him around
which is super ironic since trevor ends
up as a supporting player at this
movie's hell's gate as it opens also fun
fact palpatine actor ian mcdermott
played the porter in the famous 1978
production that starred in mckellen as
macbeth and judy dench as lady macbeth
he is accompanied by the adorable morris
whom katie calls a chicken pig but
morris is actually a dijang from chinese
mythology associated with the
personification of hundun a legendary
faceless being of primal chaos this guy
actually appeared back in wenmu's
research journal in the movie's opening
minutes alongside sketches of several
other mythological beings who later
appear in tallow they break out and
steal razorfist's car and since we never
hear his name spoken aloud in the movie
the fact that his name is written all
over his car is really the only way we
learn his name using morris to guide
them through the bamboo forest maze
until they reach tallow where morris
reunites with others of his kind and
they see lots of other mythological
creatures including the huli jing that's
a nine-tailed fox-like creature the foo
dogs these are the big lion-like
creatures that guard shrines and temples
in pairs these are also known as
guardian lions and win-woo actually has
statue versions of them at the gates of
the tin rings compound and the vermilion
bird representing the element of fire
and that turquoise horse with the face
of a dragon is the longma which really
just translates to horse dragon seeing
one of these is supposed to be
considered an omen of a legendary sage
ruler which if you think about it both
chongqi and his sister xiling will
evolve into by the end of this film the
talo people are led by guangbo played by
yuen ma legendary hong kong actor and
stuntman who worked with bruce lee in
the 1670s with films like fists of fury
and enter the dragon and the popularity
of bruce lee in particular is one of the
big influences of the shongxi comics of
that time among the people of talo is
michelle yeo as jung nan lee's sister
who explains how they are connected to
this benevolent dragon that they call
the great protector who for them has
fought off a demonic entity from another
realm that along with its smaller
tentacled drones feeds on souls now the
creature is only ever given the name of
dweller in darkness and none explains
how it fed on their vast cities that
spanned alternate realms beyond this
world this is the beast trapped behind
the seal who has been in wynwoo's head
disguising himself as the voice of his
deceased wife which is similar to
lovecraftian monsters like cthulhu and
yarlathotep who form psychic telepathic
links with mortals driving them crazy
nan says the dweller of darkness
promises your greatest desires an oddly
specific faustian offer which could link
with the cosmic dark magic of peter
parker's wish fulfillment spell in
spider-man no way home and the pulsing
beacon inside the ten rings that wong
discovers in the post-credits scene
could be setting up a supernatural
interdimensional threat that the marvel
heroes will face in doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness a villain like
schumachorath or one of the other
tentacled elder gods or the demon cathan
who drafted the darkhold and in the
comics initially cursed wanda maximoff
with her sorcery or maybe a figure like
nightmare or mephisto of whom this beast
could have been a weapon of their making
also this week's episode of what if
brought back that mysterious
interdimensional tentacle monster for
the pilot episode really the first
continuity we've seen on that series and
we've only seen just one part of that
giant creature so far it was one of many
mystic demons from other realms that
doctor strange absorbed could these
creatures be linked to the one we saw in
chongqi well while not everything we see
on the animated what if series will
cross over to the live-action mcu this
definitely parallels shangchi's hints of
this demonic tentacled monster from
other realms trying to absorb life
forces and it would not surprise me at
all if doctor strange's multiverse of
madness ends up establishing this soul
sucker and the what-if monster as part
of the same family of elder god-esque
beans if not the same creature the seal
we learned is formed from dragon scales
of the great protector dragon scales
also form the armor and the weaponry of
these tallow guardians and chongqi
receives his comic accurate suit a
fabric made of these same scales which
along with zhao ling's new clothes were
left to both of them by their mother and
nan carries that legacy of her sister by
training sheng chi in that tai chi style
that his mother used to defeat his
father win woo by opening up his fist
into an open palm and setting up shanxi
in the final battle to defeat his father
using that same kind of dance and
beautiful eye contact that we saw in
that earlier scene also in this training
dojo here the base of it is windy and
serpentine the body of the great
protector showing how in this setting
they are bound by the dragon's
protection they train up to brace for
this fight with wen wu and his forces
who arrive leading to this vicious
battle between the ten rings and the
warriors of tallow the father and son
face off but when woo blasts shangshi
into the water and begins hammering away
at the gate allowing soul suckers to
leak into this realm one of them
snatches death dealer and the two
warring sides decide to join forces
against these soul suckers because only
talo weaponry works against them
meanwhile deep in the water shang chi
awakens the great protector and
reconfronts his father at the foot of
this crumbling seal now after shangqi
failed to defeat his father using the
same wing chun combat that his father
taught him this time he disarms win woo
the same way zhang li did using the more
graceful tai chi movements bending the
rings to his will and seeing that his
great love lives on not in the impostor
from beyond but in the grace of his son
grace that persisted despite win woo's
best efforts to stamp it out when wu
learns the core lesson of this film of
ancestral grief that the pain of our
past isn't reason to destroy its fuel
meant to re-channel to bring life and i
would argue despite this being a pretty
strong origin story for chiang chi in
the mcu as a whole this movie is less of
the story of the hero but like other
great marvel films like avengers
infinity war captain america winter
soldier and black panther this is truly
the story of the villain with a complex
soul win woo is truly the heart of this
film and it makes it a more captivating
story in my opinion meanwhile slattery
hilariously plays dead morris joins him
all while the rest work together to take
down the mega soul sucker including an
amazingly lucky arrow hit by katie they
send lanterns out on the water to
memorialize the fallen and leave it to
xi'ling to dismantle the ten rings
network but as we learn in the second
post-credits scene she actually takes
over the throne and expands the tin
rings operation to return in either a
sequel or a disney plus series i
personally hope to oversee a fighting
tournament of eccentric fighters from
the mcu katie tells their friends of her
drinks that shangqi defeated the monster
by doing a kamehameha fireball of course
not a dragon ball z and yeah that is
kind of the move shang she used to kill
it and after not being believed by their
friends katie and shang chi are summoned
by wong to join them in the sanctum
sanctorum where in the post-credits
scene they meet bruce banner and captain
marvel learned of the pulsing beacon in
the rings all of which i went into in
another video but i love how the closing
image of this film has sheng chi joining
wong through a portal ring a way of
showing how when these rings glowed blew
they were heavy burdens chaining shang
chi to death to the pain of his father
but now as they glow golden they
represent a magical gateway to another
world to life for this future avenger
you can support new rockstars by
checking out our merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com like this amazing
what if shirt design that i'm wearing
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter at eavos follow and subscribe to
new rockstars thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you